bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue dans sa nouvelle configuration de
personnalités qui ont un regard acéré
sur l'époque et qui échangent leurs
opinions de préférence divergentes mais
ça on va le voir
bonsoir claire chartier vous êtes là
d'actrice en chef des pages idées de
l'express l'express qui jusqu'à demain
en kiosque une couverture consacrée à la
journaliste et militante laïque zineb el
rhazoui vous est aussi l'auteur du viol
et nous enquête sur un fléau social
ouvrage publié aux édition de
l'observatoire bon soit gabriel cluzel
vous êtes rédactrice en chef du site
boulevard voltaire vous intervenez
également vous écrivez pardon dans
l'hebdomadaire famille chrétienne est
votre dernier livre enraciné nous sommes
tous d héritier a été publiée aux
éditions artège c'est la commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale qui
s'est penché sur ce sujet qu'il affirme
là fraudes sociales représenterait en
france entre 14 et 40 milliards d'euros
par an la fourchette est assez large
mais elle montre l'ampleur du sujet la
fraude sociale au sens large
c'est-à-dire à la fois les retraites les
dépenses maladie mais aussi les
allocations diverses par exemple le rsa
écoutez ce qu'en pense à un bon
spécialiste de ce sujet et les
magistrats il s'appelle charles prat et
il donnait à nos confrères de seignosse
cet exemple de deux couples qui avait
déclaré 1200 grossesse est alors ça vous
avez eu un réseau qui a été démantelé
dans le nord c'était de couple de
roumains qui avaient créé à la base de
faux documents une fausse déclaration de
grossesse des faux dossiers et donc ces
quatre personnes ces deux couples ont
déclaré 1200 fausse grossesse et ont pu
arnaqué un million sept cent mille euros
puis alors on a fini par leur tomber
dessus quand elles ont incité dans le
nord l on finit pas vouloir les faire ça
aussi dans l'est du coude à strasbourg
donc là le 6 à 1 mille aulas en disant
non c'est bon quoi
mille deux cents gamins ça ça commençait
à se voir mais cela étant vous allez
dans l'autre sens des fausses
reconnaissances de paternité des non
verts qui reconnaissent des dizaines et
des dizaines de gamins caire et accusé
les exemples sont presque innombrables
on parle de de gens qui ont cent trente
ans qui continue à toucher leur retraite
et on se dit mais comment se fait-il
qu'on n'arrive pas davantage à à
démasquer ce genre de fraude
à l'heure de des réseaux informatiques
tout puissant en effet le juge dont vous
parliez charles pad s'est penché sur la
question donc dans son livre le cartel
des fraudes et il aimait plusieurs
hypothèses qui me semble tout à fait
juste c'est à dire que il ya une forme
de deux centres de culture de l'excusé
qui habite notre pays et et qui fait
qu'on se dit autant là la fraude fiscale
c'est des entrées riffs c'est un peu des
cols blancs autant la fraude sociale
c'est des petites gens qui sont dans la
peine
donc on préfère fermer les yeux alors
qu'il ya réellement une fraude organisée
à au delà des fraudes individuel il ya
aussi peut-être la peur d'agiter de
garde et enfin l'envi garder une forme
de paix sociale
il ya cette idée qui est semble-t-il
fausse puisque nombre de ces locations
partent à l'étranger que finalement bon
an mal an ces fraudes seraient
réinjectés dans la dans la consommation
donc certes ça plombe un peu le budget
social mais finalement ça se on s'y
retrouve et d'après ski et en creuse en
réalité il ya une grosse partie qui part
à l'étranger
et puis et puis peut-être il manque une
volonté politique
il ya de la procrastination politique
c'est sainte est dossier que sans doute
personne n'ose réellement s'y atteler
alors on peut saluer quand même d'un
certain nombre de ceux notamment une
sénatrice du diy nathalie goulet qui
s'est penché sur la question et je pense
que si le sujet montrent actuellement
dans la presse on peut dire que c'est
quand même grâce à elle et je crois que
c'est important pour de faire la lumière
sur ce serpent de mer j'ai certes et
vous partager ce constat si si on ne
lutte pas davantage contre la fraude
sociale c'est parce qu'il a pas de
réelle volonté politique
alors déjà je pense que ces dernières
années un intérêt s'est manifestée sur
cette question là pour essayer
effectivement d'éclaircir le dossier
donc y'a pas que nathalie boulay il ya
eu déjà un précédent rapport du sénat
sur cette question là beaucoup de
rapports donc on sent bien que c'est
quand même une volonté d'avancer sur un
dossier qui renvoie quand même au pacte
social qui fonde notre état providence
donc il est tout à fait justifiée
d'aller regarder à quoi servent les
impôts que nous livrons à l'état qu'ils
sont censés finalement servir à autre
chose qu'à détourner
donc ça c'est un premier point je pense
que encore une fois ya une mobilisation
qui n'était pas qui n'existait pas
auparavant et qui me semble salutaire
ensuite peut-être en effet une culture
de l'excusé il est possible que je suis
assez d'accord avec cette cette analyse
parce que qu'on veuille pas forcément à
les mettre en difficultés des petites
gens parce qu'en fait qu'est-ce qu'on
s'aperçoit de quoi en lisant le rapport
enfin en tout cas le compte rendu qui en
est donnée dans la presse de la cour des
comptes c'est qu' un certain nombre de
français sont susceptibles de frauder et
pas simplement ceux auxquels on pense
immédiatement parce que le débat public
nous mène à eux par exemple confèrent
les la famille de roumains dont on vient
de parler c'est que ça concerne par
exemple effectivement des petites gens
qui toussent une retraite assez
misérable et qui essaye de s'arranger
pour qu'elle soit un peu moins misérable
enfin l'éventail est très varié
notamment les personnels de santé sont
assez massivement représentés dans ces
fraudes à la sécurité sociale
ils ne sont pas du tout suffisamment
investi y est alors là ça va pas faire
très bien dans le décor après locaux
vides et après avoir salué tout leur
travail mais enfin bon ouais en effet
enfin le le la cour des comptes le
reconnais je crois que c'était une
députée justement d'ailleurs c'était la
députée qui avait travaillé avec celle
que vous adoptiez tout à l'heure l or m
grandjean l'amour en jean qui notait que
le personnel les personnels de santé
étaient impliqués dans 30% des fraudes
même la sécu que c'est pas rien donc
tout ça pour dire qu'en fait l'éventail
est assez varié et que c'est vrai que je
pense qu'il ya une sorte de il y avait
une sorte de volonté mais trop couverte
à mon avis c'est terminé alors on peut
tout à fait étonné je suis d'accord avec
vous il ya la première chose qui me
stupéfient franchement c'est qu'à l'ère
de l'intelligence artificielle on en
soit là là là je viens c'est même ça
renvoie presque un archaïsme de
l'administration alors juste pour donner
un exemple je j'ai vu en préparant donc
cette émission que dans un rapport
d'ailleurs dû du sénat que les changes
entre donc un problème de connexion
entre les caisses et que les changes
entre la caisse nationale d'allocations
familiales et l'administration fiscale
dans cet échange ya un million de
personnes 1 million qui ne sont pas
reconnus donc il ya quand même un
problème dans le traitement des dates à
quoi et on s'étonne avant de vous passer
la parole
je précise parce que tu n'as châtié vie
allusion que effectivement un rapport de
la cour des comptes est sorti hier sur
ce sujet mais qui lui de 2
quantifie pas l'ampleur de la fraude en
disant nous on peut dire que les
chiffres qu'on connaît c'est à dire
qu'il ya un milliard d'euros de fraudes
avérées mais qu' elle est probablement
beaucoup plus importante
c'est un problème oui mais le ce qui est
certain c'est qu'on peut par exemple
calculer leur là encore ça à froid de
faim un calcul extrêmement simple et
qu'il refait un petit peu sur les
plateaux télévisés actuellement et qui
paraît en effet enfantin il dit dallas
directeur de la sécurité sociale sous
serment a déclaré qu'il y avait à 73,7
millions d'individus qui pour faire
court on un numéro de sécurité sociale
une carte vitale
sauf qu'il y à 67 millions d'habitants
selon l'insee et on peut rajouter à ça
alors il dit allez 1,8 million de
personnes qui perçoivent à l'étranger
essentiellement des retraités
mais même si on enlève cela eh ben il
manque en fait près de 5 millions 4,9
millions c'est une soustraction
extrêmement simple de dont il ya 4 et 10
à 5 millions de personnes fantômes et ça
on se dit c'est pour ça que je peux
parler de manque de volonté politique
on se dit en effet vous avez entièrement
raison à l'heure de l'intelligence
artificielle
comment peut-on arriver à une erreur de
calcul aussi aussi énorme et ne pas s'en
préoccuper
moi je crois que c'est une question que
les politiques vont devoir explorer et
je crois qu'ils vont devoir s'en saisir
parce que cela participe à un sentiment
d'injustice actuellement un petit peu un
une envie de vérité qui qui comment dire
diffuse dans toute la société qu'on
pourrait rapprocher un petit peu de même
si c'est encore autre chose mutatis
mutandis joaillier delà de la sphère du
squad c'est à dire que on se dit bah
finalement là la loi ne ferait rien il
ya des injustices patentés pour une
forme de culture de l'exclusion il ne se
passe pas grand chose alors que
finalement ben n'importe quel quidam ce
moyen se dit alors de l'informatique ça
doit être
je pense que là une autre explication
est que très certainement ce dossier on
a perdu du temps parce qu'il est
instrumentalisé dès qu'on parle de
fraude sociale
on arrive sur la polémique les immigrés
qui profitent du système etc
c'est automatique donc je pense qu'on a
manqué de pragmatisme on a péché par
excès l'idéologie qu'on manque
pragmatisme parce qu'en effet il ya un
consensus enfin hormis bon ces débats
sur ce qu'ils peuvent tous et profiter
des allocations et qui sont d'origine
étrangère
il ya un consensus sur le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas se
permettre d'avoir cette somme d'argent
qui disparaît alors qu'on en a besoin
d'avoir réparé il fait vous voyez
vis-à-vis des populations d'origine
immigrée parce que c'est factuellement
indiqué dans dance par la commission la
sociale qui dit les les assurés nouveaux
qui sont immatriculés en arrivant avec
des documents qui viennent de l'étranger
qui sont des photocopies noir et blanc
on peut pas vérifier et c'est propice à
beaucoup trop regarder encore une fois
le rapport en face qui vient de sortir
de la cour des comptes sous les olé
quand on regarde en effet je dis pas du
tout que ça n'existe pas mais raph et
mais non et c'est même très sûrement
même j'ai été surprise je me suis dit en
lisant le compte rendu
mais c'est incroyable voyez par exemple
des gens qu'ils cessent une activité qui
finalement ne disent pas bon bah qui
sape au contraire mais bien sûr cela
peut concerner cinq ans ça peut
concerner un nombre important de
français ce qu'il ya beaucoup de sujets
finalement sur lesquels on dit depuis
les français s'imaginent que c'est lié à
l'immigration mais pas forcément champ
visuel le ça alimente le fantasme moment
alors le meilleur moyen de comment dire
de faire tourner court le fantasme c'est
de mettre la vérité à jour dans tous les
domaines c'est à dire dont tablées et
sans tabou alors pourquoi ne se saisit
ton pas de ce sujet à bras le corps
parce qu'il ya quand même des exemples
patents 2 est vrai qu'ils ont de quoi
être choquant alors charles prades site
je le cite encore lui parce que c'est
vrai que c'est lui qui a écrit un livre
sur ce sujet il cite l'exemple et il
était aux premières loges pour voir les
problèmes de par sa fonction il cite
l'exemple d'un d'un d'un djihadiste
syrien qui fils inscrit tranquillement
qui venait de belgique et 6 inscrits
alors là c'est sous un feu avec des faux
papiers pour percevoir les allocations
diverses et variées en france et et il y
en aurait semble-t-il un certain nombre
d'autres djihadistes donc ça a quelque
chose d extrêmement choquant qu'ils
percevaient des allocations tout en
allant combattre à la presse à
l'extérieur et donc c'est vrai et moi
j'ai lu dans le livre sais pas si vous
avez lu cette excideuil en livres alors
que je ne ne trompe pas titre s'appelle
la chambre des coupables froid 2
mathieu ou c'est il me semble qu'ils
rapportent les qui assistaient au procès
de djihadistes et il disait ben
finalement au cours de la conversation
on apprenait qu'ils avaient fraudé la
caisse d'allocations familiales on se
disait que finalement comparé au reste
de ce qu'ils avaient fait c'était
presque négligeable dit tout ça ça
participe quand même à excusez moi mais
là je vais me manque de parole sur terre
mais vous savez que vous n'êtes pas que
deux à débarquer aussi tous les
internautes qui sont nombreux et bah
écoute et non pas encore mais l'émission
d'enec doit qu'à sa première partie les
internautes qui sont là merci de réagir
sur le figaro.fr
merci un internaute
qui se fait appeler le libéralisme est
un humanisme d'un beau programme
ils nous demandent si la fraude sociale
coûte plus cher que la fraude fiscale la
difficulté c'est que vous voyez quand on
entre 15 et 40 milliards on ne sait pas
quelle est l'ampleur exacte c'est
difficile de répondre précisément à
cette question puisque le propre de la
fraude c'est qu'on ne connaît pas les
montants puisque les soeurs ne sont pas
déclarés si la fraude n'est pas nouvelle
nous demandent à nier comment se fait-il
qu'on ne lutte pas depuis longtemps
contre moi c'est exactement à cette
question que nous essayons de répondre
depuis quelques minutes
alain sur lefigaro.fr certains
personnels de santé fraude largement sur
des visites qui sont en fait des
consultations c'est le sujet que vous
abordez claire et puis cette remarque de
life is good selon le figaro.fr
et j'aimerais bien voir votre réaction
là-dessus l'assistanat a fait beaucoup
de dégâts
les parents ont assisté contre 3
comptent trop sur l'état providence la
fraude sociale est même devenu normal
peut-être je mets les pieds dans le plat
que s'ils avaient moins d'allocations y
aurait moins de fraudes
c'est une vision assez réductrice de la
fraude sociale
enfin je reviens ce que je disais
auparavant et vous citiez votre hauteur
est ce que votre auteur parle de ses
médecins qui délivrent des certificats
de complaisance ces infirmières qui
facture des soins alors qu'il n'existe
pas fuir il suffit de regarder c'est
beaucoup plus large
je pense qu'il faut regarder les choses
d'une façon depuis delà de la 2d
dépenses médicales
regardez on connait tous des gens qui
disent qu'ils vont faire leurs courses
avec une ambulance alors sa place taksim
et qui remboursés par la sécurité
sociale sous prétexte que qu'ils ont
peut-être aussi l'idée que les fans le
système est une vache à lait quoi il ya
peut-être ça aussi l'idée qu'on peut
servir parce que là on est dans un état
providence qui permet qui permet ce
genre de choses eh bien oui même si je
voulais cézanne et non mais simplement
je crois qu'on peut pas renvoyer une
fraude pour excuser d'autres turpitudes
c'est à dire faisant la lumière sur
toutes les fraudes je suis je
je suis complètement d'accord les une
excuse palissandre c'est vrai que c'est
5 millions de francs tonnes paraissent
éléments identifiables c'est plus
compliqué peut-être des d'évaluer le
besoin en ambulance de l'un ou l'autre
pour un pour un employé on peut le faire
mais s'il ya une volonté on peut le
faire mais néanmoins c'est vrai que ce
ce cet écart de 2 5 millions paraît
tellement simple à résoudre qu'on ne
comprend pas qu'on ne se soit pas à clé
avant il paraît tellement énorme que
alors je rappelle le livre que j'ai
cités pardon c'est la chambre des
compagnes de mathieu delahousse parce
que je n'aurais pas écorcher les et à
tous ceux qui croient que tout ça n'est
pas si grave parce que finalement c'est
l'état qui paye je voudrais rappeler ce
chiffre a tendance à oublier
à chaque fois que les que notre
employeur nous verse 1000 euros nets de
salaire il paye 820 euros
c'est la moyenne de charges pour payer
tout ça et que donc peut-être que il y
aurait un peu moins de charges et donc
un peu plus de salaire net s'il y avait
un peu moins de fraude tout ça
évidemment sans compter le revenu à la
source étaient assez justes et charges
en moyenne les charges sociales qui
finance ce système l grève de 80 % le
salaire net versées aux salariés et pour
les indépendants c'est s'est pas autant
mais c'est quand même très élevé tous
ceux qui payent leurs chèques à l'urssaf
chaque mois le savent on change de sujet
si vous le voulez bien peut-être
avez-vous vu les images de cet homme qui
s'appelle alain cocq ya 57 ans qui est
atteint d'une maladie dégénérative
incurable et qui a demandé au président
de la république de pouvoir bénéficier
d'un sédatif pour mourir
réponse négative de l'elysée parce que
c'est interdit mais cette affaire
dramatique remettre le débat sur les
soins palliatifs sur pardon pas sur les
soins palliatifs mais sur l'euthanasie
sur une éventuelle évolution de la loi
cl-s leonetti avant d'entendre vos
points de vue je voulais simplement
rappelé qu' il existe une loi la loi
claisse leonetti qui prévoit
ce qu'on appelle une sédation profonde
et définitive c'est à dire en fête qui
prévoit de pouvoir faire mourir des
personnes à condition qu'ils aient ou
trois conditions soient réunies
un que le malade souffre d'une affection
grave et incurable 2 que son pronostic
vital soit engagé à court terme
c'est-à-dire qu'ils soient proches de la
mort et enfin qu'il est une souffrance
réfractaires à tout traitement claque
chartier votre point de vue est ce qu'il
faut faire évoluer la loi ont d'abord
c'est un sujet qui est d'une gravité et
d'une profondeur humaine extrêmes donc
je pense que c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui en appelle à la sagesse
délibérative de de la société au sens
large de chacun d'entre nous
alors ça me rappelle aussi jeu là je
vais donner un cas enfin comment dire
une expérience personnelle lorsque j'ai
travaillé en espagne et à la fin des
années 90 1
un homme était vivait depuis trente ans
dans un état terrible il était
tétraplégique après être tombé d'une
falaise à l'âge de 19 ans et demandé à
mourir et évidemment la loi sur ne
permettait pas
qu'ils puissent mourir il a organisé en
fait son suicide en demandant à ses amis
de chacun fournir un élément lui
permettant d'arriver à absorber le
liquide qui allait lui permettre de
succomber et il s'est filmé et il a
diffusé sa sur une chaîne de priver mais
de spectres nationale donc ça fait
penser à ça parce que ce monsieur avait
dans l'idée au départ de diffuser ça sur
facebook qui voulait diffuser son agonie
sur facebook puisqu'il a cessé de
s'alimenter
tout ça pour dire que en fait on n'est
pas dans un cas mon avis on est dans un
cas de suicide assisté là aujourd'hui il
se trouve dans une telle situation que
la wii on bascule sur la loi leonetti
mais lorsqu'il fait sa demande au chef
de l'état il est là pas en d'état
terminal enfin terminée alors en fin de
vie quoi donc là on est dans le cadre du
suicide à six exactement comme ce round
san pedro qui s'appelait comme ça et là
que lui dit l'état en la personne de
madame macro non parce que là ça n'est
pas autorisée et en fait on se retrouve
dans ce cas-là ça c'est un paradoxe en
fait on est là face à une société qui
alors qu'elle pourrait soulager la
souffrance d'un de ses citoyens décident
de ne pas le faire pourquoi parce
qu'elles pensent que précisément en
respectant le principe absolu de la vie
elle et elle permet à ses citoyens de ne
pas souffrir dans le sens où ils
pourraient être victimes d'un pouvoir
discrétionnaire d'une 20 ans on serait
dans un an pour être soumis si on
autorise et ça a une forme voilà donc
fait une forme de protection d'un c'est
assez paradoxal terre dire qu'on fait
souffrir d'un côté et ont dit non au nom
de la non souffrance en fait donc on se
retrouve dans une situation où d'un côté
on a un cas très humain qui parle à tout
le monde
franchement ce monsieur c'est vrai que
sa situation elle est pathétique elle et
on peut à tout un tout petit peut
subodorer les souffrances qu'il endure
et de l'autre on à la rigueur du
principe avec sa froideur mais qui aussi
évidemment peut permettre de vivre
ensemble et ce qui est intéressant dans
ce cas là c'est que ça nous renvoie à la
spécificité française qui à face à ces
questions une position assez sur une
ligne d'un fils d'équilibriste en
quelque sorte elle essaye toujours de
tenir compte de la sensibilité de la
personne donc de tenir compte de la
personne et en même temps du collectif
et c'est extrêmement difficile c'est un
dilemme
je pense qu'on va devoir avancer sur
cette question là ça n'est pas pour moi
encore une fois une révision de la loi
léonetti 1 je pense que ces deux choses
différentes
gabriel plus elle nous allons vous
écouter avec beaucoup d'intérêt je
voudrais simplement pour pour ajouter
aux débats vous citer un extrait de
cette déclaration qui a été faite par la
société française d'accompagnement et de
soins palliatifs justement sur
7 ce cas elle nous dit monsieur alain
cocq fait un choix libre personnel est
respectable mais il est inexact
d'affirmer que l'agonie qu'il va subir
et celle à laquelle l' oblige la loi
claisse leonetti et elle ajoute la
société des soins palliatifs aux fins
qui est donc le cet organisme qui
regroupe les spécialistes disent ils le
souhaitent monsieur coque peut
solliciter une équipe de soins
palliatifs qui l'accompagnera le
soignera le soutiendra ainsi que ses
proches
la loi actuelle permet d'accompagner
dans la dignité
les patients atteints de maladie grave
évolutive carillon plus ce qui est
intéressant dans sa déclaration c'est
que il y le e10 parlons site ce nom de
ce mot de dignité parce que ce qui me
dérange dans ce qui se passe
actuellement c'est que ça ressemble un
petit peu à tous tout le même processus
qu'à chaque fois qu'on cherche à pousser
une avancée sauce qu'on joue enfin ce
qu'on juge une avancée sociétale
c'est à dire qu'il ya un cas tragique
moi ce monsieur je ne remets pas
évidemment en cause sa souffrance elle
est là elle est bien réelle et c'est
très compliqué de dire quelque chose
face à ça puisque évidemment comme tous
muet face à sa souffrance
et puis il y a des éléments sémantique
donc on parle de mourir dans la dignité
comme si s'il ne veut se suicider parce
que je suis d'accord avec vous dans sa
démarche c'est plus une demande
c'est exactement et bien on sait que
cela supposerait qu'il ne m'aurait pas
dans la dignité
heureusement et je crois que ce serait
au contraire à atteindre à la mémoire de
tout un tas de gens de dire que ceux qui
meurent de leur mort naturelle et
jusqu'au bout du chemin ne meurt pas
dans la dignité
ce qui est intéressant dans cette
déclaration c'est que cette association
pour les soins palliatifs des médias il
ya il ya eu il ya une alternative il n'y
a pas d'un côté l'euthanasie ou le
suicide assisté et puis de l'autre côté
des gens extrêmement dur qui parce
qu'ils respectent la loi et rien que la
loi est juste la loi vont le regarder
mourir dans des souffrances atroces
non c'est pas du tout ça évidemment ya
manière d'accompagner les gens en
développant les soins palliatifs
moi je suis toujours très triste
d'entendre des gens me dire avant ma
grand-mère est morte dans la paix parce
qu'elle est là et de très bien entouré
alité dans un elle a réussi à avoir une
place dans un service de soins
palliatifs et je me dis simplement des
malades en fin de vie 30 % sont dans des
centres de soins peuple voilà exactement
donc ça c'est vraiment une piste
intéressante à développer pour que les
gens puissent mourir dans la paix et la
série calais et et là ce serait
effectivement extrêmement intéressant de
creuser que je crois que la question de
l'acharnement thérapeutique des soins
déraisonnable c'est des questions
évidemment que les médecins s'opposent
sont pas des dd comment dire des dessins
dit qu'il ne cherche pas à faire
souffrir il au contraire tout ça ça a
été étudiée peser ces îles
il ya des décisions extrêmement
équilibrée dans ce domaine donc là on
sent bien qu'on est au-delà de ça on
voudrait se servir de cet exemple pour
vous faire passer l'euthanasie
l'euthanasie dont on sait que c'est
quand même une boîte de pandore on le
voit déjà en belgique où il est
maintenant on fait rentrer en ligne de
compte les les souffrances
psychologiques ou ça va nous amener je
vous donnais un cas je vais être
extrêmement trash quelqu'un qui perd son
enfant qui perd son enfant
on est je pense que nous sommes mère
toutes les deux c'est une souffrance
indicible
je pense qu'à un moment de votre vie
vous pouvez vous dire moi je peux pas
continuer là je ne peux pas continuer je
peux pas continuer à vivre en ayant
perdu sept enfants est ce que vous
croyez que dire que c'est une souffrance
psychologique est la pire des
souffrances psychologiques pourrait
justifier que on aille jusqu au suicide
assisté voyez c'est tout c'est ces
dérives
qui à mon avis on continue la traitement
le cas de ce monsieur
en fait son état se dégrader donc il est
noté arriver et là je parle pas de
dignité du combat de l'association était
il en était arrivé à souffrir beaucoup
ne voulais que ça s'arrête
il n'était pas en phase terminale donc
il ne rentrait pas dans le cadre de la
loi
cl-s leonetti il n'allait pas d'option
fin de vie il n'avait pas d'option la
seule option qu'il avait c'était quand
l'autorisent
voilà donc non mais c'est important de
penser au sabre dans le cas du je suis
ici et c'est pour ça que c'est différent
alors l'euthanasie c'est un mot qui
regroupe plein de choses en fait ça fait
partie de ces mots ou il faut s'employer
à essayer de préciser de quoi on parle
donc là c'est même pas une question de
mois je pense pas je vois pas du tout là
une question d' instrumentalisation là
aussi de d'un combat parce que ça existe
un jeu je suis tout à fait d'accord
là je pense pas je pense que c'est
vraiment un cas humain qui pose qui nous
pose une question véritablement profond
de société alors s'il fallait changer la
loi
c'est pas il faudrait à la limite dire
que cette loi classe leonetti elle
autorise la sédation pour des gens qui
ne sont pas en phase terminale
donc ça serait une façon mais parce que
le principe de la loi appelée au préau
mais le président de la république
le principe de la loi c'est de laisser
ce et c'est pour ça que ça irait
complètement à l'encontre de la de la
philosophie de la loi
la philosophie de la loi pourquoi c'est
tout ce qui fait la différence entre
l'euthanasie telle qu'elle est
revendiqué par certains et cette loi que
personnellement je défends je la trouve
très bonne faudrait qu'elle soit
davantage intégré bon c'est que on
laisse alors c'est subtil même parfois
considérés comme ses sophistes on laisse
la mort venir
donc ça suppose que la mort elle va pas
tarder et pardon des tracés
rude donc fait pas du tout ce qu'a donc
je pense que c'est soit on envisage en
pause le sujet ce qu'il veut poser ce
monsieur parce que parce qu'il souffre
c'est tout et c'est vrai qu'on est face
c'est le suicide assisté qu'est ce qu'il
a donc dû arrêté de s'alimenter parce
que et donc il a énormément souffert
avant de d'être finalement d'accepter
puisqu'il vient de le faire d'être
intégré dans les soins palliatifs est
donc cette affaire il ya la première
c'est celle en effet de sa volonté de
suicider de façon assisté médicalement
assistée comme on dit que voilà
et puis il ya aussi quand même et cette
envie de se montrer mais sait qui est
qui et quand même on peut le dire
dérangeante moi j'ose le dire je trouve
que cette mise en scène est quand même
un peu curieuse est-ce que c'est son
dernier combat et ce qu'il a envie de le
mettre en scène je n'en sais rien mais
la question que facebook transmettent en
direct c'est oui donc ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas que son cas il en il amplifié
pas tout seul il en est et sa femme les
5ème et 4ème du spectacle et c'est quand
même
il est un traitement dérangeant les
internautes dans notre débat qui ensuite
vous vous continuerez bien sûr à
échanger pour vous donner la réaction de
nathan sur lefigaro.fr qui est convaincu
que les gens ne veulent pas mourir mais
qu'ils veulent juste ne pas souffrir
ôtez la souffrance ils ne demanderont
plus à mourir nous dit nathan
volent manque sur youtube qui affirme
que dans d'autres pays le suicide
assisté permet aussi de ne pas payer les
soins
c'est vrai que c'est aussi l'inde est
l'un des dangers
même s'il est pas facile d'être aussi
affirmatif et puis dan sur youtube que
faire du serment d'hippocrate le serment
du du médecin dans un contexte de
suicide assisté
c'est que la souffrance pardon voyez
pour reprendre le cas que je donnais
tout à l'heure et j'avais parlé à ce
monsieur par téléphone c'est qu'il ya
des souffrances qui comptent pas soulagé
c'est ça le nom me voyais pas dans son
village mais il ya des souffrances à
monsieur avait des nausées vous même ce
monsieur écologie la veille au téléphone
venait tout la tête attendait ces mois
fédérer
il avait une souffrance psychologique
terrible qui ne va pas pouvoir être
soulagés par des traitements des
médicaments et sans même parler de ces
cas-là il ya certaines souffrances là
pour des malades qui sont même ans et je
le dis parce que je ne sais pas ce que
j'en connais qui souffrent et qui ont un
type de douleur qu'on ne peut pas se
soulager
donc il ya quand même des en fait il
faut faire attention et c'est pour ça
c'est toute la difficulté est quelque
part c'est aussi la beauté de la
démocratie de pouvoir réfléchir à ces
sujets ces sujets là c'est que c'est il
faut faire attention avec les principes
qui sont cons vous défendre évidemment
qu'on est tous pour le respect de la vie
et que l'on n'a pas envie d'une société
barbare on est bien d'accord avec ça
mais il faut aussi faire attention
parfois lorsque les principes finalement
on arrive à devenir à promouvoir d une
loi qui devient étrangère à ce qu'elle
veut ré attendait alors à ce qu'elle
veut oui
williams se fasse attention aussi ne pas
ne pas ouvrir cette boîte de pandore là
aussi partir au cir sur des grandes
déclarations d'hier
il ya des souffrances qui sont qu'on ne
peut pas soulagé la plupart des
souffrances quand vous en parler à des
médecins peuvent être soulagés encore
faut-il avoir le cadre le cadre pour
pour les soulager
par ailleurs il ya des gens qui ont
envie de mourir à l'instant t si vous
avez eu des gens autour qui des malades
et qui à l'instant t + 1 n'ont plus
envie de mourir on et puis on a des cas
c'est pas interdit de regarder les pays
qui nous entourent et de voir sur quoi
ça a débouché en belgique il ya des
médecins qui ont été acquittés a quitté
donc on a jugé que ce qu'ils avaient
fait n'était pas un crime parce qu'ils
allaient procéder à l'euthanasie d'une
jeune fille de 24 ans qui était qui se
disent en grande souffrance
psychologique elle était peut-être à ce
moment là du reste un jeu après une
déception sentimentale elle était par
ailleurs dépressif
est ce que est ce que c'est cela qu'on
veut ouvrir chez nous c'est vraiment des
questions extrêmement extrêmement
troublante et je crains qu'une fois de
plus on se réfugie derrière un cas
particulier pour faire sauter un
interdit qui est quand même tu ne tueras
pas c'était quand même à la base de
notre civilisation faut pas éluder
benabbad
c'est vraiment parce qu'on a fait ce
soir pour ce que ce débat intéresse je
vous renvoie aux déclarations de nicolas
bedos ce réalisateur et écrivain sur son
compte instagram il est très favorable
lui à l'euthanasie le il le dit et vous
pourrez prendre connaissance de ce texte
que vous découvrez peut-être à l'instant
et puis je vous donne le
point de vue de nos internautes à qui
nous avons posé cette question faut-il
revoir la loi leonetti sur la fin de vie
en france et bien c'est oui à 80% et
puis ce commentaire de babineau qui est
un peu un voilà que la partie appelée de
ses voeux et qui vous dit je trouve que
l'on devrait pouvoir adapter la loi au
cas par cas
la loi actuelle est un obstacle à la
dignité estime babineau et puis cette
question de nathan qui est une question
quasiment philosophique est ce une
évolution un progrès de la société que
de refuser systématiquement la
souffrance j'aimerais quand même qu'on
arrête d'utiliser ce mot dignité si
c'est possible a eu dans le n 1 non non
non mais parce que je crois que ça
serait intéressant pour sortir du débat
voyez vous voyez ce matin des vidéos de
gens qui disaient mon beau-père qui
avait la maladie de charcot et hal en
belgique il a pu mourir dans la dignité
je connais beaucoup de gens qui sont
morts de la maladie de chercher dans la
dignité
jean que j'aimerais que cette ce mode de
dignité ne soient pas lésés dans ces
termes sur ce point d'accord que
l'émission se termine merci beaucoup
pour la qualité de vos échanges merci à
nous à merci à vous par peur de nous
avoir suivis j'y arrive et pointu
revient demain même heure même endroit
bonsoir